[Music Plays]
>> Interviewer: Please join me in welcoming
Anne Rice to Google.
[Applause]
>> Anne Rice: Thank you.
>> Interviewer: As we proceed I’ll ask questions
of my own, but I’ll also be including some
questions that fans that submitted to us online
in advance of the event today, who I hope
have tuned in to watch.
And after the Q&A we’ll open the floor for
questions from the audience.
Uh, so my first question for you Anne is,
werewolves?
In my mind they’re as big a part of the
paranormal pantheon as vampires but I’m
curious what inspired you to go there.
>> Anne Rice: Well actually I had never really
considered doing a werewolf novel but I got
a suggestion, “Why don’t I do it?” from
a very good friend, Jeff Easton.
And I’ve never met Jeff.
Jeff is a producer.
He’s the creator of the TV show White Collar
on the USA channel.
But Jeff and I are e-mail buddies.
I’m a fan of White Collar and we connected.
And he just happened to send me an e-mail
saying that he had just watched a documentary
on werewolves, the legend in werewolf fiction,
and he said if you ever tackle that, if you
ever write a werewolf novel I will buy buckets
of hard covers.
[Laughs]
>> Anne Rice: Just a casual mention and for
some reason it was just the right time for
me to think about it.
I wanted to return to gothic supernatural
fiction.
I really wanted to get back to it.
And I was stuck on a novel, I was writing
about Atlantis and I couldn’t go forward
because the science was overwhelming me.
And it was, it was turning into too much of
a sci-fi thing, it was made for Michael Crichton,
not me.
You know?
And I was, and, okay, then comes this e-mail
and I thought, “Well maybe I can do that
now.
I mean, why not?”
And I started to think about it and think
about what I wanted to do with the werewolf
mythology and what had not satisfied me in
other werewolf films that I’d seen.
And in about 3 months the novel was done.
>> Interviewer: Wow.
>> Anne Rice: Yeah it worked out very well.
I wrote Jeff the other night after the novel
came on the New York Times list number 3 and
said, “Do you have any other suggestions?”
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: You know, he’s a good muse.
>> Anne Rice: Right!
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: So what about the legend appealed
to you?
>> Anne Rice: Well, the transformation.
The idea that you, well what appealed to me,
what if the werewolf, what if the man or the
woman was completely conscious during the
transformation?
You know, the way we get it in movies and
books often, the person is not conscious.
They lose themselves in the transformation,
become almost a rabid beast and really don’t
behave like a wolf so much as they behave
like a mad dog.
Then they wake up the next morning and the
village is filled with rumors of people being
torn limb from limb in the woods, they realize
they did it, and the whole thing ends with
a silver bullet, you know?
But I thought, “What if the subject is conscious?
What if instead of being an agonizing transformation
this is something sensuous?
“I know what it would mean to me if I could
grow muscles and several feet taller.
You know?
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: And get really, really strong.
You know?
And I thought, “Okay that might feel absolutely
terrific.”
And I explored it from that point of view.
And my hero, Rueben, stays conscious all during
it.
He can talk.
He can talk quite clearly when he’s a werewolf
or a man wolf.
And what he really becomes is a man wolf rather
than a 4 footed animal.
It’s more like Ron Chaney, in the original
black and white movie, whose always running
around in his shirt and trousers.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: Right.
>> Anne Rice: But my man wolf does not run
around in his shirt and trousers.
But he’s upright like this.
You know?
He’s anthropoid, whatever.
But, um, again what I wanted to explore was
how he responds to this.
What do you do the next day?
You remember all of it.
He even photographs himself with his iPhone.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: That’s a wonderful scene
actually, you know?
Him trying to paw his iPhone and take a self-portrait,
it was very meta.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: But isn’t it exactly what
he would do?
You know?
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: I mean, so he does it and he
e-mails that to his computer and then when
he wakes up he’s fully expecting those photographs
to show him in a normal physical state and
a psychotic mental state, but still he sees
photographs of exactly what he remembers.
>> Interviewer: Right.
>> Anne Rice: That he was a man wolf.
>> Interviewer: And he has a really great
moment, I think, early on when he’s realizing
his transformation and he’s madly researching
werewolves online
>> Anne Rice: Right.
>> Interviewer: And he finds that they’re
really pretty one dimensional and his experience
is so different and were you writing him with
that in mind, thinking about how to add, sort
of, the human experience to his mildly unexpected
animal?
>> Anne Rice: Really what I did with him was
really just what I would do if it were happening
with me.
I would research it online immediately.
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
>> Anne Rice: I would, you know, these are
all the things I think anybody would do.
Often in horror fiction, things like this
are presented in such another worldly realm,
that there’s no real hook into what we would
actually do.
You know, we go to see werewolf movies and
vampire movies, in which nobody seems to guess
that they might be vampires or werewolves.
I wanted to put Reuben in the real world of
Northern California, right in our own time.
And he does, he looks up everything.
And he makes the news as the man wolf and
he’s a reporter.
So he’s actually asked to interview one
of the people that he rescued.
While he was a man wolf he attacked a rapist
who was attacking this woman, and the next
day has to interview her for various reasons
that are explained in the novel.
But I had a lot of fun playing with all of
that.
I mean, I think I started over 35 years ago,
taking the comic book image of the vampire,
The Man in the Black Cape, and getting into
that character and trying to say what’s
the real deep back story to this?
Where’s the tragic dimension if the vampire
is a real being.
And I’m really doing this same thing with
Reuben and him being a man wolf.
>> Interviewer: When you talk about his transformation
and him being conscious through it and it
being, it’s so much more ecstatic than it
is agonizing.
You know, that whole American Werewolf in
London thing doesn’t happen which I, um,
which is so different.
And I think it’s an example of how you’ve
been creative with archetypes before, you
know, you’re vampire’s aren’t afraid
of garlic and crosses and things like that.
>> Anne Rice: Right.
>> Interviewer: But his killings are quite
violent at the same time, so would you, what’s
happening with him in sort of that pleasure,
plain conflict?
>> Anne Rice: Well he finds he enjoys, very
much, killing and that though he’s conscious
and he’s Reuben, he still has all these
hormones surging through him as a beast and
he’s able to kill without much hesitation.
But he can differentiate between innocence
and guilt when he’s in that state.
And he kills guilty people.
He kills kidnappers, rapist, people like this
and he does not harm anybody who’s innocent.
In fact, it’s almost impossible for him
to do that.
He can smell evil the way a dog smells fear.
And he can sense innocence the way dogs often
sense helpless people, handicapped people
or people who are challenged in some way.
And what he has to do when he comes back to
himself is ponder whether he has the right
to kill people evil or not.
Whether, I mean he’s doing things that he
can’t morally forgive himself for.
But it’s also very alluring and he discovers,
just like the vampires in my books, that he’s
resilient, that he heals from almost any kind
of wound.
So that makes the power, the gift, all the
more alluring.
There’s no way that he’s gonna give it
up.
And again I was asking myself, “Well what
would you do if someone, you know, gave you
the capacity to be immortal, possibly immortal,
and definitely resilient?”
And I would find it almost impossible to give
up.
>> Interviewer: One of our fans, Fab, of Sherman
Oaks California, asked, “One aspect of Reuben
Golden is his ability to smell good and evil
in humans.”
He said, “I think about my pets and how
they love some and nearly bite others, I wondered
if that’s how you got that idea.”
He wishes it was a character trait that we
all had to be able to sniff people out.
>> Anne Rice: You know we probably do have
it on some level.
And dogs have it, a stronger ability to sense
things, maybe, from physical cues and glandular
activity and I did get it from animals.
I did get the idea from dogs.
I heard a story of some friends of ours that
had a dog that would play very roughly in
the back yard with all the kids but when a
child came out of the house that was very
handicapped and challenged, the dog would
go over to that child and protect it, just
walk beside it into the yard.
And the animal was totally transformed.
Nobody had to teach that dog that.
He sensed that that child was different, that
it had trouble doing the things the other
children were doing.
And I think that went into my concept.
I mean, this is after all a myth of somebody
turning into an animal.
So I was thinking, “Well what are the mysterious
characteristics of an animal that are going
to be really preternatural to him when he
goes through this?”
>> Interviewer: You mentioned earlier how
you looked to, sort of, that comic book, sort
of, hero model that he has this, sort of,
this black knight quality.
And I was wondering if you, as he discovers
that the gift is a means to save lives and
it’s a means for good, he becomes, you know,
with his obsessive documenting and his heroic,
sort of, running to the rescue a curious blend
of Clark Kent and Bruce Wayne.
Um, do you see some classic comic book hero
in him?
>> Anne Rice: Oh yes.
>> Interviewer: Or were there certain stories
that really came to mind beyond?
>> Anne Rice: No I was consciously exploring
that dimension.
That he does become Batman or superman.
You know, and how does he live with it?
And I absolutely love doing that and you know
looking, again, for the tragic dimension behind
those images and I’ve been doing that since
I did Interview With a Vampire.
And what’s it like to be a vampire, what’s
it like to talk, if you can get a vampire
talking about it.
I think it’s, I think it’s something I
truly, truly love.
>> Interviewer: Do you think that you’ll
write more books in this series?
Is this the first?
>> Anne Rice: I think definitely.
But I have other books I wanna write first.
I’m doing another supernatural novel and
I wanna get that done first and then maybe
a sequel.
I think it’s a good idea to wait a little
while.
The sequel you would write the next day after
you finish a book, it’s not really the sequel
you would write a year later, or two years
later.
You learn things, you think about things,
you see possibilities that you don’t see
immediately.
And I wanna give that little interval there.
What I don’t know, I never know what’s
gonna happen.
I’m looking forward to going home and spending
the next few months just writing and if Reuben
gets into my brain, I might go ahead and do
the sequel right away.
>> Interviewer: One of our fans submitted
a question about what you’re working on
next.
She said, this is FantasyFreak of Philadelphia
Pennsylvania, she asked, “On a few instances
on Facebook you alluded to work on a new book
that appears to be a ghost story, can you
reveal any details about this?”
>> Anne Rice: You know, I don’t want to
because I talked a lot about that novel about
Atlantis and then I just can’t make that
book work.
So I would just prefer to say that it’s
a supernatural novel and It’s in this same
spirit as The Wolf Gift or Interview With
a Vampire and I’m hoping that in a few months
I’ll have the manuscript.
>> Interviewer: Wonderful!
Well, I for one am very excited for that.
Um, you did take a break between Interview
With a Vampire, and you didn’t write The
Vampire Lestat until almost ten years later.
>> Anne Rice: Actually it was eight years
later.
>> Interviewer: Eight years later.
And you did some books in between that.
>> Anne Rice: Right.
>> Interviewer: So that’s a style that has
worked for you in the past and it’s,
>> Anne Rice: Well it worked at that time.
[Laughs]
>> Interviewer: I had another, I had another
two books that I really wanted to do after
Interview With a Vampire but I’m very glad
that I got into the Vampire Lestat and that
it worked.
Cause that, the Vampire Lestat is really the
book that launched my career.
I was doing really well, I had nothing to
complain about as a writer, but Interview
With a Vampire was actually a flop, it did
not do well.
It was so strange.
People didn’t know what to make of it.
And it actually had a life as a hard cover
book that flopped, basically, and didn’t
sell and then it had life as a paperback bestseller
briefly and then it became, sort of, an underground
book.
And that was kind of wonderful finally.
But the Vampire Lestat that sort of put me
on the map.
>> Interviewer: And he’s written so large
in that book I mean, that’s his debut.
>> Anne Rice: Yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Anne Rice: Probably love him more than any
character, I guess, I’ve ever written.
[Laughter]
>>Interviewer: Do you have a second favorite?
I have to ask that as a middle child.
[Laughs]
>> Anne Rice: Well, you know I’m in love
with Reuben right now.
You know, I’m always in love with the latest
creation.
But Lestat, I mean, that was, he’s almost
more than a literal character to me.
I’m always haunted by him.
I mean, I’m always thinking of what he would
think of places and how he would like this
hotel or that hotel or this view or what he
would think.
[Laughter]
>>Anne Rice: It’s, you know, I don’t know.
He’s sort of alive inside me in a way that
some of the other characters have never been,
you know?
>> Interviewer: One of our fans, Artist of
Ideas from California said that, “My favorite
book beginning of all time is I am the vampire
Lestat.
I am immortal, more or less.”
And she wanted to know what you’re favorite
first line was.
>> Anne Rice: Wow, uh.
Favorite first line, the first line is the
hardest part of the book.
[Laughs]
>> Anne Rice: It’s absolutely the worst
part.
That might be it; I don’t know that I can
top that.
>>Interviewer: It’s pretty fantastic.
>> Anne Rice: I don’t know.
And that first line came from desperation,
I mean, the book was done and I just said,
“I got to get into this somehow.”
[Laughter]
>>Anne Rice: So I went back and worked on
the beginning and I came up with that.
Okay just say it, “I am the vampire Lestat.”
>> Interviewer: And it totally captures his
voice from the beginning.
That’s just who he is, right there.
Andy, another fan, asked if you’d ever consider
continuing the Vampire chronicles or going
back to them.
>> Anne Rice: I don’t wanna say no to anything
right now.
>> Interviewer: Yeah.
So I’ll get back to Reuben, to your favorite.
I would love to know more about him and how
you, um, how he came into view for you.
I mean, he’s this well to do, young, handsome
sunshine boy, they call him.
You know, driving his Porsche up to Mendocino,
like, who is he?
How is he the likely or unlikely, uh, person
to encounter and survive a wolf attack?
>> Anne Rice: I think when you write, or when
I write, I put everything I know into a character
but I really don’t know how that character
is going to develop.
And in the cliché they come to life on the
page is really true.
If they don’t come to life for me, uh, I
have to do another book.
[Coughs]
>> Anne Rice: Or the book doesn’t work.
But he really just came to life.
Walking up this hill in Mendocino County talking
to this woman Marchant Nideck about her house
and I guess he really came to life when I
hit on the idea that he was very good looking
but he was kind of uncomfortable with it.
And he wanted to be taken seriously.
And that he’d been a person that had never
been taken seriously because one he was very
good looking and two he was fairly well off,
and people tended to dismiss him as superficial.
But he really had a lot to offer and that’s
when he began to work for me as a character.
I began to see his frustration with that and
his longing to be taken seriously and how
uncomfortable he was inside that beautiful
body and face, you know?
I think many, many women probably feel that
way, maybe more than men, but there are probably
men that feel that way too.
I remember once a man telling me that when
he was young his physical looks had nothing
to do with who he was and it was very disturbing
and jarring for him.
And as he got older he was more comfortable
in his skin.
So, but why that made that character come
to life I don’t know.
The character I kept seeing physically was
the actor Matt Bomer from White Collar.
Who’s an exceptionally beautiful guy, I
think.
And also kind of unassuming and boyish and
seems to me, maybe, he’s a bit uncomfortable
being good looking.
>> Interviewer: I think what’s interesting
about Reuben to is that he’s very, he is
a really, um, dedicated to this career as
a journalist and he’s an obsessive researcher
and he’s hungry for information all the
time.
And I think about him in that aspect next
to Felix Nideck who’s also, you know, sort
of, becomes his ancestral, sort of, foil and
who is also, you know, obsessed with information
and history and collecting stories.
How do you see there, sort of, for me they’re
the twin figures of the book, and how do you
see that?
>> Anne Rice: I think definitely Reuben falls
in love with the figure of Felix Nideck because
he sees him as a mentor, as a model.
>> Interviewer: Right.
>> Anne Rice: As a man who’s obviously a
scholar and curious who traveled all over
the world seeking knowledge and Reuben loves
that idea.
He loves that very, very much.
In fact, you know, in the novel he goes to
live at Nideck Point, the house where he was
bitten or became a werewolf and he’s looking
for all the answers up there.
But it’s sort of like he moves from a family
where he’s so uncomfortable and so underappreciated
and so much loved and dismissed, he moves
up to Felix’s family basically in Felix’s
house.
So he chooses that path.
And, you know, when I’m writing I don’t
really calculate all that it just happens.
>> Interviewer: Right.
>> Anne Rice: I’m writing away and this
is what happens, you know?
Um, and it was a great pleasure to write that.
I think if you focus on writing what’s really
exciting to you and what’s really intense
to you, many other aspects of the book take
care of themselves.
Like, I used to worry a lot, at the beginning
of my career, that I didn’t put enough meaningful
things in the books, that the book wouldn’t
be perceived as shallow.
But what I realized was that I was putting,
if anything, too much for some people, philosophy,
theology
[Laughs]
>>Anne Rice: Questions about the meaning of
life and so forth and what I came to realize,
in my work, those questions will always crop
up.
All I have to do is kind of get the characters
going and into motion, get very excited and
wanna know what’s happening next as I write
and the rest will take care of itself.
But that was part of what took care of itself,
his gravitating toward Felix.
>> Interviewer: Do you think that, um, the
supernatural environment that you find yourself
writing in is that a more fertile ground for
you to explore some of these bigger questions
about faith and spirituality.
These bigger existential questions, you know,
like there’s something about that world
or those, you know, that identity help bring
of those ideas and thinking to the surface?
>> Anne Rice: It’s the only way that I can
explore those questions.
I simply cannot write pedestrian realism,
I tried.
I knocked myself out as a creative writing
student trying to write about experience,
I couldn’t do it.
It was when I chose this, that absurd title,
Interview With a Vampire and when I started,
you know, writing through the voice of the
vampire, and it was a comic book image, that’s
when the door opened to my reality.
Then I could talk about everything that mattered
to me, absolutely everything, grief, pain,
good and evil, conscious, everything.
Tragedy, horror, the fear that life was meaningless,
just a million things I was able to talk about.
But before that I was completely ham strung
as a writer.
Just couldn’t do it.
Way out of step with everybody.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: How is it for you, and I don’t
know how or wanna assume that you’ve read
a ton of the contemporary sort of vampire
fiction that’s out there now, but that,
um, the feel of those stories is very different
from yours.
You know, they don’t have that gravitas
really in a lot of the characters and, um
, which is not to say they’re not great
stories and you know, creative and clever
but is it strange for you to encounter those
creatures that you know really well but rendered
so differently.
>> Anne Rice: Well I’m enjoying it.
>> Interviewer: Yeah.
>> Anne Rice: I really am.
Authors like Stephanie Meyer and Charlaine
Harris, are doing things with the vampire
that never occurred to me to do.
I never thought of doing it.
[Coughs]
>>Anne Rice: I think for me it was very important
that my vampires be heroic and mythic and
at the same time intimate with the reader.
You know, talking slang, talking naturally.
But they always, for me, had this glamour,
this important glamour, this important mythic
dimension.
And what Charlaine Harris and Stephanie Meyer
are doing is domesticating the vampire.
You know, basically saying it’s the guy
down the road.
It’s the guy you’re gonna meet at Sam
Merlotte's, you know, when you go for a burger.
Or he’s the guy next to you in biology class
in high school, which really never occurred
to me.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: You know, in the Vampire Diaries,
it’s the same thing vampire’s in high
school.
It’s a genius stroke but for my immortals
they would not go to high school, you know,
that would be
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: the last option that they would
choose.
But, so I read some of that with a smile,
you know?
But I think, I understand, I’ll admit the
audience loves it obviously, it’s a lot
of fun.
I think the concept of the vampire is so rich
that we’ll see even more surprising developments
with it.
>> Interviewer: Do you have any predictions
with what’s gonna be the next big?
>> Anne Rice: No, I could never predicted
what I’ve seen so far, so.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: So I wouldn’t try to make
a prediction.
>> Interviewer: So without spoiling the story,
for those that haven’t read The Wolf Gift,
I was wondering if you could tell us a little
more about Felix Nideck and the six men that
appear in the portrait with him at the estate.
>> Anne Rice: Well from the very beginning
of the novel, these six men, friends of Felix’s
and Felix who disappeared twenty years ago,
there are, or maybe it’s fifteen years I
don’t remember the exact number, but they
disappeared and they loom over the book and
there is a mystery there.
Where did they go?
They, Felix has been declared legally dead,
or the house wouldn’t be for sale and Reuben
wouldn’t be there writing a story about
the house being for sale.
But he falls in love with Felix and really
wants to know more about him and to me that
was a very interesting mystery to prompt.
What happened to Felix?
How it happened.
Why nobody ever heard from him again and I
had to reveal that as the book went on.
But the real subject of The Wolf Gift is really
Reuben and how Reuben deals with everything
that happens to him.
>> Interviewer: Right, and The Wolf Gift also,
I think, this is something that I just, always
appeals to me in fiction there are wonderful
names and I think Reuben Golding is a very
distinctive name, but Felix Nideck, Margon
Spangler, you have these wonderful, creative,
unusual names, I wanted to ask you, if, when
you’re developing characters, like, where
do names fall in the process?
Do you start with names or do they come to
you as you’re writing?
Do you have particular places you turn for
inspiration?
>>Anne Rice: They’re the hardest part.
If I don’t have the name of the character
I can’t get going with the character.
Reuben’s name just came to me, I love the
name Reuben.
It seemed perfect for him.
That wasn’t too hard.
But I often have to stop and think a lot about
the other characters name that I have.
And Marchant I made up that name.
I never heard the name Marchant.
And I made it up.
But, uh, it’s hard and if you’re dealing
with other worldly characters, characters
from former ages and or aliens or whatever,
it’s very hard now to choose names for them
because names have been used all over the
internet by bloggers and fanfic writers and
game makers and so forth.
So you can’t just name somebody Malkya you’ve
got to go look and make sure that that’s
not a major, you know, game character or something.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: And so it’s just very difficult.
But I actually go to old name books.
Jewish baby names are really, really good.
Biblical baby names and I look through any
source for names.
And anytime I’m reading anything that I
come across a really great name, I’ll jot
it down, whether it’s a last name or a first
name.
And a character’s sometimes born when I
hear that name, like Margon.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: That’s good.
That’s such a strong, you just don’t forget
it.
And I think, you know, said that in the beginning,
your names are really distinctive and those
characters really fell around them.
Do you have any names, like prior names for
characters now like famous?
Like that you changed with step or have you
always just known?
>> Anne Rice: Memnoch the devil, when I created
that character, first he was Maximilian, but
it was much too ordinary a name.
I love to make up a name that doesn’t exist
and Memnoch didn’t exist.
Lestat didn’t exist.
Now people are coming up at signings and showing
there’s baby named Lestat.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: Wow, that’s.
>> Anne Rice: For about ten years it was pets.
Alice Cooper had a dog named Lestat.
That was great.
Now it’s babies.
The name is working its way into respectability.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: One of our fans, Brandon of
Kentucky, asks “With each of your works
your readers find themselves thrust so vividly
into a richly detailed universe, that loving
your worlds and characters is effortless.
Can you describe one of your favorite characters
or places in your new novel and why?”
>> Anne Rice: You mean in The Wolf Gift?
>> Interviewer: Yeah.
>>Anne Rice: Well Nideck Point making that
house.
I grew up in love with houses.
And in love with houses in fiction, in Dickens’
Great Expectations there was this incredible
where Miss Havisham lives.
This doomed lady who’s still in her bridal
gown thirty years after being stood up at
the altar.
And Jane Eyre was a novel I loved and there’s
Rochester’s great big spooky house in Jane
Eyre with the mad woman in the attic.
And I love to create houses and Nideck Point
in this novel is sort of the tribute to me
for all the great houses I came to own as
I fulfilled my dreams.
I lived in some pretty spectacular houses
that were a hundred, hundred fifty years old.
I don’t, now.
I live in a very small, very ordinary family
home where I’m very comfortable.
But I had to sort of build Nideck Point almost
block by block, floor board by floor board.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: Added the materials of all those
other houses, and I love doing that.
And I love doing the origin stories, you know,
where vampires came from, where werewolves
came from.
And I loved doing that in this book.
>> Interviewer: That’s one of the questions
I wanted to ask you about because Felix has
this notion about werewolves being an ancient
sort of super race and you know, one of our
fans, Ben of Salisbury Maryland, said he loved
the Vampire creation mythology and Queen of
the Damned and he wanted to know if there
were other origin stories that you’ve drew
upon for The Wolf Gift or did you just create
this?
>> Anne Rice: I think I created it.
You never know.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: But I think I created it.
>> Interviewer: Was there a particular point
in history or culture that was a good spring
board for you in thinking about, sort of,
the wolf lineage.
You talk a lot about these tablets and cuneiform,
and there’s something, I don’t know, Tigress
River to me about the whole, the whole....
>> Anne Rice: Yeah.
They’re definitely, in the book, they’re
searching for something and it’s never entirely
revealed in the book what they’re searching
for.
But I took the idea of wolves all the way
back to a time in history when you didn’t
have just homosapien sapiens but you had a
couple of other species out there.
I can’t pronounce the names of those other
species.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: But you know now we’ve found
fossil evidence that there were at least two
maybe three other species of human that were
also occupying the world at the same time
as homosapien sapiens.
We outlived the others.
Not just Neanderthal but a couple of others
that were different.
And so I’m tracing the werewolves back to
that time in history.
>>Interviewer: And how do they find themselves
in the Northern coast of California.
Like, what made you set your cumulative, sort
of, dream house in that beautiful setting?
>> Anne Rice: Well the presumption is, I think,
without it ever being said is that they're
all over the world in different places.
But, they come to that place because it has
the great North Woods, it has the great beautiful
Redwood forest and they do love being out
in the forest and being beasts.
I mean, they, when they’re not.
[Laughs]
>> Anne Rice: Running over rooftops and intervening
and tearing rapists to pieces and stuff, they
also like to hunt and be in the forest and
just behave like wolf men, like beast men.
I think that’s what drew them to that part
of the world.
>> Interviewer: Did you spend time there as
you were writing the book just to, sort of;
get your mind in that space?
>> Anne Rice: No but I had spent a lot of
time there.
I lived in Northern California for thirty
years before I ever went back to New Orleans
and, uh, where I lived for eighteen years.
But, and, during the time when I lived there
we often went to the Redwoods, to Muir Woods
and to Marin County and to places in the wine
country and in Mendocino County.
So I was very, very familiar with it.
Right after I finished the book I did go up
and visit every single place I had written
about and made sure I had not misremembered,
and I had a wonderful time and it turned out
my memories were quite true to the atmosphere
and the feeling, everything I remembered.
It was wonderful to go back to Muir Woods
after all these years and walk again through
the Redwoods.
I stayed in Mill Valley at the hotel where
Reuben stays.
I went to the restaurant where he meets Laura
in the book for breakfast, you know, I love
to do things like that.
I love to go pick the sets.
But it’s often after the book that I do
that.
>> Interviewer: Was it very different for
you thinking, like being in that environment
versus New Orleans where so many of your books
have taken place?
>> Anne Rice: Well to me it was a wonderful
environment because it was also haunted and
gothic, I mean, the idea, the windy Northern
coast to me is just as mysterious as the English
coast is, so in a novel like Rebecca you know,
where you had Mandalay burning down the coast.
But I find it just a great place to be.
To me the forests are gothic and ghostly.
I don’t feel the present of ghosts but I
don’t feel them in big houses in New Orleans
either, you know?
So I loved exploring that bringing, I guess,
what would be my gothic sensibility to that
landscape.
I’m sure other authors have done it I just
haven’t come across it.
But I found it a natural thing to do.
>> Interviewer: Are there other locations
you have in mind for future stories, places
you’d like to explore?
>> Anne Rice: Yeah, but I don’t know what
they’ll be yet.
I really don’t, um, there’s so many places
that I love.
And the first thing I think about in any new
place is, “What am I gonna write about this?”
You know?
What am I gonna write about Google Headquarters?
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: Well you have a wonderful
ability to capture, um, the environment that
you’re in.
I think that house and that certainly those
woods are characters in their own right, so
much drama happens there and it’s just really
transported right away.
So, I’ve always loved that about your books,
certainly I’ve never been to New Orleans,
but I felt like I had been there time and
again through all the times that I read your
vampire books.
Um, let’s see.
Before we open up the floor to our audience,
um, I wanted to ask you a few more of our
fan submitted questions that are here today.
Um, Tammy of Kenmore Canada and Valley Tile
of Tarzana Canada, or California that one
and other fans were interested in your writing
process, in particular, they wanted to know
what kind of research and preparation you
do when you’re starting a new book.
>> Anne Rice: Well, I can do a lot of research,
um, and sometimes way over research because,
you know, researching for me isn’t just
finding the answers to questions or accumulating
facts or details, it’s getting inspiration,
and its ideas, plots, chapters, incidents,
all that springs to my mind during research.
So, it’s a, it’s a wonderful preparation
for writing.
But, for the Wolf Gift I didn’t do very
much, I mean, I researched the legends of
werewolves but I had done that before with
the vampires, so I had read all that material.
And when I researched the witchcraft persecutions
in Europe, I read about all that.
So really I didn’t need to go back and read
very much more.
Uh, the writing process, once I actually start,
once I make up my mind to leave the dreamy,
beautiful, seductive, engulfing world of research
and actually get down to work, you know.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: And narrow down the possibilities,
I write very fast.
And I plunge, and the hardest part is always
the beginning, it is the worst part.
The first forty, sixty, eighty pages of the
novel take most of the time.
But once it begins to flow, really begins
to roll, I like to get it done in two months,
or three months max.
You know, if it goes any longer than that
it doesn’t bode well for the book.
And it doesn’t, if it’s done in two months,
that’s the best, that’s the optimum period
for me because it’s all fresh in my mind,
it’s all right there and random access memory
is totally there and if I can do it in even
shorter time that’s better.
But, I write all day, I usually start in the
morning.
I get up; drink coffee, read the New York
Times, read the L.A. Times and the Desert
Sun
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: You know the suburban paper
where I live.
Then I go online and talk to my Facebook people
of the page whom I love and I usually post
some stories from The New York Times, so we
start talking about politics like the republican
primary or, you know, the war on women in
America and their rights
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: You know, things they’re concerned
about.
And we get into quite a few discussions on
that and I get to work finally around ten
o’clock, maybe ten thirty.
And when I’m writing a book I’ll work,
from say, ten thirty, break for lunch, go
back and work all afternoon and knock off
maybe eight in the evening.
I don’t like to get totally strung out anymore.
Writing eighteen hours straight is too, I
get too crazy when I do that.
And I knock off at eight and usually gravitate
to something that will just take my mind someplace
else, like I’ll watch a crime show, White
Collar.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: I just watch something that
diverts, but it’s usually a narrative.
I can’t watch sports, I can’t figure out
what’s happening.
I go to watch, I don’t know, Law and Order,
full of 15 million re runs or whatever.
Whatever will just divert, I mean, if something
wonderful is on like Downton Abbey, I’m
watching Downton Abbey.
Or Pillars of the Earth or Game of Thrones
or whatever, real high quality, whatever the
highest quality I can get of TV.
And that’s my writing habit.
When the book’s really going well, so that
I get out of bed wanting to know what’s
going to happen, I will just barely do anything,
you know, I work in my flannel nightgown.
I have hundreds of flannel nightgowns.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: Like Laura in the book, she
has hundreds.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: Yeah.
>> Anne Rice: I have hundreds of flannel nightgowns.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: And I live in those gowns if
I can 'cause it’s the simplest garment,
it’s just a sack.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: You don’t have to worry about
anything.
>> Interviewer: Well you have to be comfortable
if you’re gonna, you know, give yourself
over to something that...
>> Anne Rice: Yes.
Yeah, and that’s one of the great things
about being a novelist is, for me, it’s
that I can work at this thing that I’m totally
engulfed by and obsessed with, it’s just
divine.
You know, I’m so thankful that I’ve been
able to do this in my life, wonderful.
>> Interviewer: Well if you’re writing these
wonderful books in two months, I think you
must have a very happy editor.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: She must love that you have
such forward momentum.
Um, another question from Cornelius Offdark
he says, “Miss Anne Rice, would you ever
write a werewolf versus vampire novel?”
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: I don’t think so.
I don’t think so.
In the past I did unite two groups of my people
and I’m not sure it was the best thing to
do, to unite them, Um, I, but they do share
the same world and there’s an organization
I invited called The Talamasca, which is supposed
to be an ancient order of people who track
supernatural activity in the world.
And they probably will definitely enter the
world of the werewolves, but I’m not sure
I’ll bring all the other entities out there
into contact with them.
I don’t think there’s any reason why my
vampires would have any problem with my werewolves,
you know, if they did know each other.
I think they’d be fine with each other.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: Band of brothers.
[Laughs]
>> Interviewer: Do you ever imagine one of
your own books getting that, kind of, Game
of Thrones treatment, like seeing it in a
kind of dramatized that way?
I mean, I know you have some experience with
that.
>> Anne Rice: There’s not an author in the
world right now that wouldn’t work with
HBO on a series like Game of Thrones.
I mean, we all want that.
It’s, we totally want that, but how many
times can you call your agent and tell them
that?
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: Right now, um, Imagine Entertainment
has optioned to tell The Body Thief, the fourth
of the Vampire Chronicles and they’re gonna
do that as a movie.
But maybe someday in the future, you know,
there could be an HBO series of the Vampire
Chronicles, I would love it, everybody, who,
I mean we’re in a golden age right now,
I think, of costume, historical, and fantasy
drama on TV.
There’s never been a richer time.
I’ve never seen shows with these production
values like the Game of Thrones series, and
I thought it was just terrific, really first
rate.
And I think the Tudors and Pillars of the
Earth and Downton Abbey and all the different
costume and historical dramas, the Elizabeth
miniseries about Elizabeth the First, it’s
just wonderful stuff.
Spartacus, I mean it’s over the top and
it’s great, all of that.
So this is a great time for fantasy writers
and writers of historical fiction.
It’s just a wonderful time and I think we
all dream of having our stuff done well.
>>Interviewer: So my last question for you
is from one of our fans, Gerard from San Diego
asks, “My dear Anne, what message do you
wish the reader to draw from reading The Wolf
Gift?”
>> Anne Rice: Oh, well first of all I want
you to enjoy it and never forget it.
If you don’t enjoy it, forget the rest,
you know?
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: You know, if it’s not fun
to read if it’s not enjoyable, if it’s
not exciting, nothing else matters.
But I hope it’s about us, it’s about everything
we go through, what we feel about the transformations
we experience and how we have to deal with
them.
I think supernatural fiction doesn’t work
unless it’s really about us.
Unless it’s about our souls and our hearts
and how we feel inside as outsiders and how
we feel alienated and how we sometimes feel
like monsters, it’s all about that.
>> Interviewer: Thank you.
>> Anne Rice: Sure.
>> Interviewer: So we’ll open up the floor
to questions from the audience here.
>> male #1: Miss Rice, you’re an unabashed
follower of Christ, how much does that influence
your writing?
>> Anne Rice: I’m sorry, say that again.
>> male #1: They say you’re a rather outspoken
follower of Christ.
I was just curious how much that influenced
your writings.
>> Anne Rice: A follower of Christ?
I’m not sure that I am in the way people
generally mean that, you know?
Faith in God is very, very important to me,
but I’ve broken with organized religion
and, um, it was a very long painful experience
for twelve years I tried to be a believing
member of the religion and my, my break with
faith was theological and social and political
and it was total.
So, I don’t really know, I feel like all
of life is a spiritual quest.
I’ve been on that quest since I was a kid.
I’ve been through many phases of it and
now I’m a little bit discouraged, but also
perfectly at peace with knowing that I’m
back with the same questions I was asking
before my conversion.
I’m back more with the questions I was asking
when I wrote Memnoch the Devil.
Then when I wrote the two novels about Jesus,
that I wrote, but I will say this, writing
the two novels about Jesus was, for me, a
joyful experience and I think they’re some
of the best writing I was ever able to do.
They’re not what my readers wanted, basically.
They have, sort of, another entire readership.
And I hope someday all of it will be viewed
as having a continuity 'cause I see the continuity
of the journey.
>> male #1: I see it too, thank you.
>> Anne Rice: Sure.
[Pause]
>> female #1: Miss Rice, thank you for coming
to Google today, um, my question is, what’s
on your nightstand?
What’s in your “to be read” pile?
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: Actually a book on mitochondria
by Nick Lane, about cells.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: I’m trying so hard to understand
how molecular life began in the world, you
know?
How life formed and the kind of strange cell
life that they’re still finding evidence
of and hypothermic vents and things like this,
I’m fascinated by all that.
But I’m almost scientifically challenged,
I mean, I really can’t understand it.
So I look to writers like Nick Lane, who are,
he’s a biochemist and almost a poet of science
and that’s really what I read.
I read a lot of nonfiction.
I read a lot of books on history.
I read some books on trying to get a historical
perspective on this amazing time we’re in,
where we are experiencing things that really
the world never experienced before, like abundance
and affluence for most people.
But I don’t read very much fiction at all
and when I do I generally grab up my favorite
books by Charles Dickens and look to him for
lessons on how to write.
So, anyway, Nick Lane is what’s on my nightstand,
definitely.
[Pause]
>> Interviewer: What’s your favorite Dickens
book?
>> Anne Rice: Great Expectations for sure,
you know the one with the big house.
[Laughter]
>> Interviewer: Of course.
>> Anne Rice: And the spooky lady.
[Laughter]
>> female #2: Hi Anne, thanks for coming today.
I wanted to know how you get over writers
block.
>> Anne Rice: How I get over writers block?
The only way to get over writers block is
to write through it.
You have to fake it 'til you make it.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: You have to remember that you
can always throw away what you’re doing.
You have to play tricks on yourself.
You have to say, “Okay just write and at
5 o’clock throw it out.”
And whatever you need to release yourself,
something’s inhibiting you, something’s
telling you you can’t do what you want and
you’ve just got to write through it.
And usually that works, and if that doesn’t
work, um, there are certain movies that I
turn to and certain books that almost always
stimulate me and make me want to create.
And two of the movies are Amadeus and Immortal
Beloved, a movie about Beethoven.
For some reason when I watch those movies
I want, very much, to write.
And that’ll often do it.
And then there are books I pick up and they
can be anything from Anna Karenina by Tolstoy
to the Executioner's Song by Norman Mailer
to a Sidney Sheldon novel called The Other
Side of Midnight or the Godfather.
They’re books where there’s a big narrative
drive and a world that you get engulfed in
and that will make me want to write.
I’ll get stimulated in that way.
>> female #2: Great.
I have a follow up question.
At what point in your life did you realize
you wanted to become an author?
>> Anne Rice: I knew when I was a kid that
I wanted to do it and wrote long, long, what
I called novels but they weren’t.
You know, the 25 cent notebook in 1951 probably
had about 50 pages in it.
But I wrote stories in the 5th grade and 7th
grade and passed them around.
And I lost sight of it when I went to college,
talk about writers block.
I was blocked for, I guess, eight years.
But I was learning so much in college that
I didn’t have much to write, I was absorbing.
And then when I was a graduate student at
Berkley, that when I realized that I really
didn’t wanna pursue the PhD in English Lit,
that I really wanted to just write, even in,
no matter what that meant.
And I withdrew from the program to really
put all my chips in writing.
I’d written stuff all along, at various
times in graduate school, not so much as an
undergraduate.
But I remember that moment because it was
hard to get into Berkley and especially for
someone who had been a bad student, as I had,
and had, kind of, worked their way up to the
point where they could get accepted in a great
program like that.
And I thought, “If you withdraw this, you
know, you’re life will be maybe filled with
risks rather than any kind of security.”
But it was definitely the right thing to do.
I went back to San Francisco State and finished
up my Masters in Creative Writing in English
and ever after really just put all my chips
on writing.
>> female #3: Thanks.
>> Anne Rice: Sure.
[Pause]
>> male #2: Hi.
I wanted to know what you thought of the movie,
Interview with a Vampire, and the casting.
>> Anne Rice: Uh, Interview With a Vampire?
Well, I liked it.
I was really surprised by how true it was
to the spirit of the book, and how excessive
it was in the way that the book was excessive,
so I was very, very pleased.
I had never envisioned it with American actors.
I had always thought of it to have British
actors simply because I felt that they did
such a better job of articulating that they
would have the quality of these European vampires
you know, that they would convey it all better.
I felt that it worked.
I felt it was successful for a number of reasons.
And as the years passed I came to see that
it was a very rare thing that had happened
there.
The producer David Geffen had pulled all the
stops out to do it on a larger scale and to
be faithful to the book and I was kind of
amazed at what happened.
You know, I would say, I can’t watch it
because it’s too personally intense for
me to watch.
But I feel I was very fortunate to have my
book made into that film.
>> male #2: Um, follow up questions.
I know there was controversy with the casting
of Tom Cruise as Lestat, but did you ever
meet Tom Cruise or speak to him about it?
>> Anne Rice: I talked to him a number of
times but only after I saw the film and he
was very charming, very nice guy, very nice
guy, exceptionally nice.
And I was very happy with what he did.
Um, you know, could it have been different
with different actors?
Probably so but I think it was very successful
for what it was.
It really was, it was remarkably faithful.
I mean, It’s a very eccentric book, very
eccentric.
And they really did it, and I think Jordan
was a very talented director, still is, exceptionally
talented.
But I got over that casting hump, I mean,
you know.
I mean, what happened was that I spoke out
against the casting and was very angry about
it but David Geffen sent me an early video
of the finished movie and a lot of people
wouldn’t of done that, I mean that’s a
risky thing to do with a movie that you are
gonna release and you hope will make a lot
of money.
But he mailed me that video and I was swept
away by it and I still had his home phone
number from when we had been speaking to each
other and I called him and told him I said,
“It’s really terrific.”
And that changed everything.
You know my relationship with them and the
movie was pretty successful.
It wasn’t as successful as they had hoped
but it was for a long time it was the highest
grossing R rated movie for years, it was the
highest.
>> male #2: Well thank you.
>> Anne Rice: Sure.
>> female #4: Hi Miss Rice, thank you so much.
My favorite series are the witches.
If you could speak a little bit to your inspiration
for those.
>> Anne Rice: You know, that’s a complicated
story.
I started The Witching Hour when I still lived
in San Francisco and I only had a few chapters
and I didn’t know for sure where I was going
with it.
But something was preventing me from writing
it.
And we moved back to New Orleans at that time
and I ended up moving into a house which was
the perfect house for the Mayfair family in
the novel.
And the novel just took off and it is filled
with all of my, um, energy and happiness of
returning to my hometown of New Orleans and
finding it as beautiful as I had remembered.
And the novel just unfolded with tremendous
energy and it was in many ways my attempt
to do great haunted house movie, that’s
the idea I started with.
I read The Turn of the Screw by Henry James
right before I plunged into it.
And I wanted to do a big dark house, a ghost
that was persistent and horrifying and scary
and I think it was some of the best writing
I’ve ever done at trying to get at the ambiance
of being haunted and being afraid of the vision
that shakes you to the root.
But, so much went into those novels, the Mayfair
Witches; they’re everything but the kitchen
sink books.
I mean, everything I knew and was feeling
was just going into those books.
And the house, I put the house I was living
in in there.
I described everything that was going on.
It was a great, great experience, um, I don’t
think those characters lived for me as much
as the vampires do but only because I felt,
I guess I completed their world in a sense.
But I loved writing them.
>> male #3: Thanks very much for coming to
speak with us today.
I wanted to ask about you, I know you’ve
gone through some adaptations of works that
have not been faithful to the material.
What comes to mind for example is the film
Exit to Eden.
How does that affect your writing after that
when you feel that what you’ve done has
been very misinterpreted?
Does it throw you off for your future projects
or are you able to really deal with it?
>> Anne Rice: No, it doesn’t throw me off
in terms of my writing but it does make me
much more cautious when talking with people
who say they want to make a film.
I mean, what I’ve learned is, that there’s
no consensus amongst these people as to what
my books mean.
I can think the book is clear, you know, that
it’s all, its priorities are very clear,
and then they take away something totally
different.
The people that made Exit to Eden saw it as
a comedy, just a rocking satirical comedy.
They had no real interest in what it was about.
And that was a sobering lesson, a sobering
lesson.
And, of course sometimes it’s a grave disappointment
like with the movie Queen of the Damned where
there really was no attempt to be faithful
to the Vampire Chronicles at all there.
They simply wanted to take the names and some
of the ideas and make what they called a new
franchise.
And that was very wounding and disappointing
and that set back any effort in Hollywood
to make any more movies based on my vampires.
It was devastating actually.
But I talked to those people, I know what
they were thinking, there was no getting through
to them.
They had no interest in the readers, they
had no interest in talking to me they simply
said we’re going for a new franchise here.
That was what they wanted to do.
So, it doesn’t affect my work so much as
it affects my relationships with them.
You can take the attitude of take the money
and run or you can take the attitude of be
very, very careful and try to control what
happens.
But the truth is, I don’t think an author
ever can control what happens unless you,
for some reason, have an enormous amount of
power.
Even if you do, even if you’re the producer
on the project you have a lot of power you
can still be completely overruled.
You can sit down with people who are your
friends and they’ll sit there and nod at
everything you say then they will turn around
and do something so different in that movie
or musical or whatever that you just be aghast.
That happens all the time in Hollywood.
One great thing about being a novelist is
it’s not a collaborative art form.
You do it all yourself.
You know, all yourself.
And if your editor says, “I don’t get
this part.”
You can always say, “Well I do.
Shall we go to press?” and usually they
will.
Or if she says, “Can you make this a little
clearer?”
Usually you can, but it’s not collaborative.
It’s not like Hollywood where they come
in and just change everything and you have
eight, ten, twelve people involved in every
decision to where there’s no singularity
of vision—to use [inaudible name] phrase—there’s
no singularity of vision controlling the project.
>> male #3: Thanks very much.
>> Anne Rice: Sure.
>> male #4: Thank you for coming.
I’m curious about what got you inspired
to write books like Violin
>> Anne Rice: Can you talk up?
>> male #4: Of course.
I’m curious about what got you inspired
to write books like Violin and Cry to Heaven?
>> Anne Rice: You know, I love music with
all my heart and if there’s anything I would,
I dreamed of being it was a musician, a violinist
or a singer.
And I don’t have any musical talent at all.
[Laughter]
>> Anne Rice: You know I tried.
Nothing.
And those books are filled with my love of
music and the way I perceive, and the musician
is a tragic hero or heroine.
And I tried in those books very much to get
what the world of music was like and what
music itself was like.
That’s what they were trying to do, you
know, and to me there very, very personal
books.
They have a lot to do with what art is and
what art demands of us and how we can save
ourselves in art.
How we can save ourselves through art.
And I think the subtext of Cry to Heaven too
is that you can save yourself through sexuality
in art even when horrible things happen to
you.
You can through love and sexuality and music,
you can redeem yourself.
You can live a great, heroic and productive
life.
>> male #4: Thank you.
>> Anne Rice: Sure.
>> Interviewer: Well if you don’t have any
other questions I hope you’ll join us downstairs
in [inaudible] to meet Anne and to have your
book signed.
And if you don’t have a book, to purchase
a book.
I’d like to thank you all for being here
today for this wonderful event.
>> Anne Rice: Thank you.
[Applause]